become getting rich is not an act it is
a habit so it is staying poor it's also
not an act it's nothing just happens to
you it is a habit
most people they listen to a webinar
they watch a video and they say oh this
guy's making whatever how much money
online I could do that and they jump
into it and then they try for 3 months
and so all this thing doesn't work why
do you think people watch reality TV you
know what I thought my life is a mess
but look at these people on TV instantly
if you better buy yourself need
motivation watch your top team with
believe nation what's that believe
nation it's Evan my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from immigrating to Canada at age 14
with zero money and not speaking any
English to failing 13 separate
businesses to now becoming one of the
highest paid consultant in the real
estate game he's Dan Locke and here's my
take on his top ten rules of success
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one learn more when the first business
opponent that I had it was like a
basically he was my neighbor at a time I
was trying to be a mother business and
he sold me on the concept oh you need a
website and I pay him some money a long
story short he's basically scared me out
of like hundred fifty thousand dollars I
lost all my mom's money all the savings
and I didn't know anything about into
the marketing and then right after that
because that experience was so traumatic
for me from then on everything I do I
said I want to learn in a hundred
percent so I went and at a time internet
marketing I bought the corey rudl course
and remember the insider secrets to mark
on the internet right that the two big
binders like 600 pages I went through in
two days
Wow and from then on I was just like
reading every I forget about like
reading a book a month and I was reading
a book every two three days so that
experience change how I operate and that
that's hard about this hunger to learn
yeah as much as I could so I would feel
I don't think it's a healthy thing is
when I went to Tony's event unleash the
power within yeah I don't know this is a
healthy thing but I always have this
feeling of no I need to know more right
I need to know more
rule number two my personal favorite I'd
value I was knocking on door and no one
like I was not gonna hey do you wanna be
the Milano no we don't need that we're
only a - yeah at a time I had my mom had
a friend my aunt she had a printing
business right like you know printing
business card and wires and all that so
I went to my aunt I said why don't you
know you print a bunch of flyers
I would help to distribute in the in the
neighborhood like printing service but
yeah they're two sides are flying right
between 5,000 of these yeah I'll run
around now I'll distribute it on the
other side can I put my stuff on yeah my
lawn mowing service it's like Oh what
the heck right yeah it's all been always
very entrepreneurial yeah you know how
to you know be resourceful in the city
yeah yeah yeah cuz a lot of people
wouldn't have even tried that cuz
they'll say well I don't have the money
for lawn mow or I don't have any of that
so it stopped them right yeah it's a
good proof
right there that it's not about what you
have it's about what you do with what
you have hundred percent we're exerting
that even at a young age it's never lack
of resources I think it's a lack of
resource fulness and and I was just
resourceful I had no money so I had time
I can put in effort and I distribute all
five of your flyers I ran home and I was
just waiting for the phone I thought I'm
gonna get rich yeah oh my god five five
thousand people I'm like I'm gonna to
get a hundred phone call or I'm gonna
pour my time I'm still going to school
I thought I'm gonna make like House
Isabella's right right
one hour no call one day no call three
days not a single one now let's check
the flush get I put in a wrong number
right no the right number right not a
single phone call on the flyer all right
and and I learned okay there's something
that you know you can have a great
product a great service but if you don't
know how to get it out there your
marketing in and get people to pay
attention no one's gonna buy from you so
I came with an idea I thought to myself
and this affected my philosophy for the
rest of my life man is a philosophy so I
thought think back the very first client
I had could pay me 20 bucks
what did I do I mow the lawn first
before asking anything in return that's
how I got that first $20 right right
yeah I thought let me do that again so I
ran around the neighborhood and I found
one of the most probably one of the
higher-end expensive homes in the
neighborhood and I saw the lawn was like
up to this high like high and I just
found it fun a day and it just mowed and
I think that this is illegal
I'm not an advocate of that but I did
that so you didn't even knock on their
door you know the whole lawn right I did
the whole thing right and I finish the
whole thing and I set at the front door
waiting for the homeowner to come back
okay she is funny it's a housewife she
came back and she couldn't she couldn't
recognize her lawn this is this lot
right yeah she's 12 pi and then she
drove back and she pulled what the hell
is going on right and she's like who are
you like I said you know I said just a
kid I'm trying to make you know make
some money
I provided services of fly oh this is
awesome you know my husband travels all
the time
he never is ever home I can't do this
stuff thank you so much you make my lawn
looks like she gave me $100
Wow $100 right and that affected me for
the rest of my life so my business
philosophy until this very day if you
say one of my motive for for business
add value first before you ask anything
in return yeah that's how I always
approach you know how most business
people they approach somebody yeah they
want to sell them some right right or
they want to hey man you do something
for me or like you know social media
people come to me all the time
oh they feel like just because I'm
successful that I'm obligated to help
them right you can show easily or so
usually we'll just give them the chase
you got to gotta earn it so my
philosophy is any interaction with
people how can I add value to what you
do it's always my most favorite the
question is is what is the most
important project you're working on like
an ad value tune
rule number three improve yourself many
years ago when I first met my mentor and
I was telling him about all these
businesses that I started I said hey you
know Alan I mean I started all these
businesses and somehow I don't know man
I'm not I'm not making enough money I'm
struggling I don't know why my yeah my
my customers they're like cheap they're
very difficult to deal with
and oh man I don't know the economy and
it's kind of sucks and I think I paid
too much in taxes I mean I was rambling
on and complaining and bitching of all
these things and he said stop I said
what is it stop I said what do you mean
[ __ ] stop is it it's very simple Dan let
me teach you something it said if your
business sucks is because as a business
person you suck I said what no us no I
work hard I said I was very defensive I
was like I learned and I try to try to
do my best and and try to serve my
customers said no you suck as a business
person
he said if if you've got sales problem
it means you suck as a sales person if
you've got employee problem it means it
sucks to you and you are managing the
business leader
it's very very simple remember this your
business is always a reflection of you
your business always reflection of you
nothing more so if you think about it
why most businesses fail I think why
most business fail it because the reason
the intend most people they stopped the
businesses for the wrong reason they
start the business because they want to
get out of a job
they started business because they want
to they want to make money of course
nothing wrong with that they start a
business because they think maybe
there's an opportunity it sounds like
it's easy where the big money is not it
started for the wrong reason versus they
see a need in the marketplace this skill
there's a this expertise is some valid
it could bring to that particular
industry right there's something that
you could bring to think about it it's
like if think of starting a business
like flying a plane and you can't just
say well I'm passionate I have a great
idea let me fly that plane
well you have your food I've you fly
plane before no do you know what if I
play no do you know where you're going
no but looks like fun let me go on a
plane one of the chances of you crashing
very high and that's what statistics
shows 90% of small business fare in the
first five years even the ones who
survive after five years most of them
don't don't pass the million dollar mark
it's just kind of surviving and that's
why people go into business for the
wrong reason and they go into business
without the proper training without the
skills I could tell you when I had all
those failures when I started all these
crazy businesses and why they fail it's
not because the vehicle is because of me
as a business person that I didn't have
the business acumen I didn't have the
business experience I didn't know
anything about leadership marketing
sales negotiation raising capital any
these skills I have today so everything
I did it didn't work because I was a
lousy business person I sucked as a
business person but a lot of them were
mistakes and that's the good thing about
business you can suck many many many
years when you get better you learn from
it you get you suck less and when you
practice and you dust yourself off
deliver mistakes
you suck even little less until whether
you wake up you say you know what I
don't suck no more and one win in
business can make up a lot of losses one
win can make up for all your losses
rule number four set wealth triggers so
you notice I have a lot of wealth
triggers in my office and so it's not
just decorative item everything means
something too right so I have like you
know the LK that's thought that
represents personal branding yeah so I
can think about that like leadership
energy and your shirt wisdom so
everything is that in my office
I wanted to call them wealth triggers
yeah you should this [ __ ] create certain
type of feeling environment for me right
I was believing environments more
powerful yeah yo your willpower right I
want it sturdy so I have meetings you
awesome on that salsa burger every week
goes yeah yeah and then have the Chinese
kind of Friday in there
I'll see if I can translate that
basically means they kind of like the
outer wall and battles one before
they're the font right and and your
decisions affect affect with the the
outcome of the battle even your like
thousand miles away right let's rush me
out that's cold
I like the John I love it rule number
five find mentors I tried most things
like most people I rep this success
books and already she's thinking Grow
Rich and how to win the friends
influence be her right you know back and
forth many times like all these books
and you know I would get up in the
morning and I would look in the mirror
and say I'm successful and that would be
a great day affirmation information and
and I would I would visualize it put me
in a vision board you know I did all
that stuff right here so you know
yes yes you know all right that's right
so it was okay I think all those things
they helped but really that the turning
point was when I find my first man boy
his name is Alan Alan Alan and at that
time Alan was here and one of the the he
was the founder of a ring with the
investment network in Canada which was
at the time one of the largest real
estate investment network in Canada and
how did you find him
good question is I want to ask you that
because there might be somebody
listening to this or watching this that
might be on their 12th or 13th failure
yeah right at that turning point so it's
somebody sitting there and kind of
confused how would how did you find your
mentor and what would be a recognition
oh I'll tell you how I found a mentor
and I'll give then I'll give them the
advice of where to find so at a time I
was just like an opportunity junkie okay
I know money's our attendees like free
seminars and I would get on these like
mailing lists right and Alan was running
one of the largest financial seminar
companies in Canada he was the first one
that brought waka Kiyosaki mmm from Rich
Dad Poor Dad I was kinda shocked before
even the Kiyosaki was famous it was the
first guy so I was getting all these
junk mails Direct Mail like not not
Instagram Facebook right direct mail
right yeah and I would always always be
fascinated by the way that he would
write these sales letters right and I
would collect them mm-hmm I would
collect them put in a real punch didn't
put them in a binder and I would save
them and will study them just fascinated
by the way he communicates right so the
copywriting on top right here and he's I
remember the name Alan Jack's right this
is name and at one time was attending a
free conference or seen sitting in the
back and I was watching the speaker
Jenna a gentleman sat down next to me
and watching the speaker was looking at
you I was looking that's like I know
there's a name ken yeah it's just
Alan Jack's Wow and I thought no way
yeah
no way and I said are you Alan jacks he
said yes I said are you the one that's
hosting these events inviting these
letters and it's like yes I am going
home
right that's my internal dialogue I try
to be calm right as I'm a huge fan
yeah like I love what you do and he
thought I was referring to the event but
yeah yeah you know we'd do pretty good
events I said no no no no I study your
letters here as I collect them I tell
them I I collect these letters and he
was shocked because I don't think he's
ever had anyone telling him that all
right young guy 2020 someone 21 years
old my pocket handing out my copy right
yeah like collecting the junk mail and I
was just faster they said I said I said
mr. Jackson can i buy your lunch mm-hmm
and I always remember to reapply he
pause he said what the hell I gotta eat
yeah that was the start of a
relationship Wow
and we had lunch we talked for hours and
then I afterwards I asked him to be my
mentor which he turned me down mm-hmm
and I was again not recommending this I
was basically stalking him in his office
why I rented office everyday if we tell
you it physically go there I'll do the
office I would say anything I would pick
up the trash anything yeah I was just
demonstrating I want to help anything
yeah I don't care about money I don't
want a salary I don't want anything and
and finally a monthly that's okay I just
need to hire you just so this is this is
like this is spotting me so much money
he's part of my staff fine like this
young man it's like crazy right and he
did and I worked for him for almost for
a year for next to nothing
that was funny story so we would do a
lot to write mail right so we stuff
these envelopes and I will help stop the
envelopes and you know the envelope the
stems and I would like that liquid
envelope right and I would put the after
about two weeks of that he said Dan you
can actually use water for that Oso Oso
doe it's getting poison a licking five
envelopes like that and put the whole
thing in
but that's how I got started right
that's like how naive I was I was just
hungry
rule number six get good habits we are
what we repeatedly do human beings we
are creatures of habits you notice that
you kind of do the same thing the same
routine over over and again and again
and again see become getting rich is not
an act it is a habit so it is staying
poor it's also not an act it's not
something just happens to you it is a
habit so let me teach you the three best
habits of rich people the very first
habit of rich people and that is they
count their money poor people don't
count their money they get a paycheck
they deposit their paycheck they spend
the money they have no idea what the
expenses are you have no idea how the
money flows you know this poor people
they alb they have a job and wait till
maybe once a year when they found out
they would tax return is the Texas that
I own is how much of the pay they look
at the numbers do you even look at the
numbers it's just okay all right
that's what how much I need to pay
without tax return and death yeah look
at it maybe maybe once a year rich
people we don't do that we look at our
numbers regularly we are financially
literate I'm not a numbers person don't
get me wrong okay I'm a concept guy okay
I'm a big-picture thinker I'm a
visionary but I am very very careful and
I'm very aware how my money is flowing
habit number two is they pay themselves
first now you've heard of this before oh
yeah I know
then I've heard of this this before you
gotta pay yourself do you know actually
what that means paying yourself doesn't
buy yourself a car it doesn't mean
taking that vacation it doesn't mean
that you know you would you know you go
blow money on entertainment oh yeah I'm
paying money myself
no that's paying everybody else when
you're buying a car you're paying the
automotive motive company when you're
buying a house you are paying the bank
when you are traveling you're paying the
the traveling agency you're paying the
hotel you're paying the the flight
company airplane
company ping yourself meaning that you
put your money aside and you invest your
money now I'm not talking about being
frugal you know if you know anything
about me
you know my work I'm not talking about
being fool girl and being cheap I'm
talking about taking a pass percentage
of your income and putting that aside
pay yourself first and save it and then
you invest it habit of rich people
number three and that is rich people are
constantly improving their earning
ability because you might be thinking
Dan okay I want to pay myself first but
I'm not making enough money I'm only
making a few dollars in a month i
couldíve I couldn't even afford to pay
my bills how am I gonna pay myself first
first of all you gotta have the habit of
paying yourself first if you're not
paying yourself first even a tiny small
percentage when you're making 30 40 50
60 100 thousand dollars a year I
guarantee you when you're making a
million two million dollars a year
you're not paying yourself it is a habit
that I'm talking about and in order to
do that in order to be able to every
single year to be able to pay yourself
more and more and more and put into
investments you need to improve your
earning ability you need to find ways
how you can add value to the marketplace
how to add more value to the marketplace
so every single year your income it's
going up every year if you've been
you've been working in house in the real
world and you have your own business and
your income kind of stays flat for the
last two three five years and shame on
you it means you're not learning it
means you're not thinking it means
you're not growing every single year
your income you have to strive to
improve that your earning ability and
the rich people we're always constantly
looking for ways to improve our earning
ability but also looking for ways to ant
leverage to apply leverage into what we
do rule number seven don't have
unrealistic expectations and why do you
think so many people fail in spite of
the best efforts you know a lot of
people watching this right now they've
maybe tried different ways of making
money online or building businesses why
do you think is the the main reason why
a lot of people fail I think that two
main reasons the first one is I think
because of the whole internet that they
have people have this unwilling to and
so Stefan is doing this is that kind of
YouTube channel and he's doing Kindle
publishing and I want to do that
you know I maybe I'll make some videos
to what they don't see is how many years
of effort that you put into it
so most people they listen to a webinar
they watch a video and they say oh this
guy's making whatever how much money
online I could do that and they jump
into it and then they try for three
months and so all this thing doesn't
work yeah right oh they jump into the
next thing
Bitcoin whatever now it's Bitcoin so
hard right oh and then and then they try
that and then try for three month old
that doesn't work they try the next
thing so I think that expectations
unrest expectation need to lead to
disappointment and failure rule number
eight have a healthy mind and body I saw
a couple comments on YouTube people
asking or Dan do you recommend these
like mine stimulating our mind and
hinging drugs the answer is absolutely
not if you follow my work you know I
don't smoke I don't drink and I don't do
drugs
I don't even drink coffee why I drink
like honey green tea that's why I drink
and water and maybe from time to time
you know cook zero when I'm watching a
movie or something like that that's it
no drugs no cigarettes and no alcohol
why is that because you notice a lot of
times even with my own story my father
was actually a very heavy smoker I want
to say he said hey he was an alcoholic
but he drinks quite a bit he enjoys a
glass here and there and I do notice
later on when he had to stroke he had
all the when his health was in it was
declining a lot of those habits
contributed to that if you don't have a
healthy body a healthy mind there's no
way in hell you'll be able to sustain
the stress the the pressure it takes to
be successful so I don't think you need
those things you only need those mind
and hands in
drugs to be successful to have more
clarity and all dish if you want to
enjoy a drink here and there that's
perfectly fine I'm just saying I don't
do it I don't need to have alcohol to
have a good time and when I drink I like
people if hey Dan just a zip of beer
it's ok enjoy they don't taste good to
me quite frankly I mean they taste like
right they don't even taste good to me
so I don't enjoy I don't need those
things to have a good time if I have a
good time good company good friends good
conversation I have a good time and I
don't need to get high to do too I get
high on doing what I love I get high on
just life I get high on being the
impacted people rule number nine up your
thermostat alright great ideas alone are
not enough why great ideas along are not
enough to change our lives you see one
of the great mistakes that most people
make is they are tending to change their
body there are chairman telling to
change the relationship they are telling
to change the income their finance they
are tending to change something outside
of themselves in searching something
that's inside with themselves some
people see themselves as conservative
and unsaved are they gonna do anything
crazy are they gonna go bungee jumping
or skydiving no unless you drunk or
something like that so you're not gonna
do anything crazy or Act not unless
you're drunk now you might say it's the
alcohol but really it's just you finally
getting permission to be yourself the
alcohol is just an excuse if you are
playful if you're fun if you're
outrageous you're gonna talk differently
gonna move differently you're gonna
dress differently maybe in a red suit
and you're gonna do things differently
and there's no right or wrong but most
of us have trapped ourselves in an old
self-image and never really update who
we are today so then when you go and
learn a new skill when you go learn a
new ability a new idea but we're stuck
in this self-image this is who I am and
that's why we never surpass it let me
give you a metaphor this would make
sense for you let's say in this room
that we set the thermostat at 70 degrees
let's say that 70 degrees it's a
metaphor it's a what metaphor for your
comfort zone which is also known as your
self-image your comfort zone and most
people have goals that are larger
they're more than their self-image and
that's why most people don't get to
their goals unless they alter and or
expand their self-image so 70 degrees is
your comfort zone
70 degrees it's your body not your goal
not where you want to be eventually but
what you're comfortable with
70 degrees is your the amount of love
and passion and connection you have in
your personal intimate relationship
again not your goal but you know what
where you live with what you live with
regularly 70 degrees is the amount of
money that you need to make to be
comfortable not your goal what you're
comfortable with let's say the
temperature drops to 65 degrees now what
happens is your brain goes hey hey hey
I'm a 70 degree or not a 65 the heaters
kicked on you feel this a drive and this
dis urge and you want to do something
about it by show of hands how many I've
ever had experienced part of life maybe
your body maybe your income maybe your
relationship where it dropped and you
fell it's not good enough and you fell
this incredible try to do something
about it yeah but without way I'm gonna
say oh yeah oh yeah and from there and
you try something and it doesn't work
and you try something else and it
doesn't work and you try something else
and it doesn't work now after a while
nobody wants to be a disappointment no
one no one wants to feel like a failure
in their lives so what some people do is
they lower the thermostats they lower
their expectations they make their goals
smaller more realistic more reasonable
don't get your hopes up or you'll be
disappointed well you know maybe maybe
not I'm not a 70 70 degree maybe our 65
degree air
look at those 70 degree people so
arrogant so fooled themselves they're
probably workaholics anyway I'm being
smart I'm cutting back I'm downsizing I
don't want to burn myself out I don't
have more balance in my life now before
you know it they're 62 they only at 58
now by the way when you add when they
add when they ask if th today Hara hang
around with 70 degree people no they
hang around with 50 degree people so
they feel better about themselves on a
regular basis why do you think people
watch we are the TV
you know what I thought my life is a
mess look at these people on TV
instantly if you better buy yourself now
but you're at tax obviously you're not
like that you're an overachiever yes
you're no achiever so when it's when
it's supposed to be a 70 degrees yes 65
what do you do you do something about it
yes you don't settle you try it try
something else it doesn't work you try
something else it doesn't work you try
something else it doesn't work you don't
settle you don't give up and you don't
give it
if you hit a wall you go around it you
go over and you go under it whatever it
takes you do it and and do you stop at
70 degrees no you keep going until you
hit 80 85 90 91 92 93 99 degrees and
your brain goes hey hey hey what do you
think you're doing up here you're not an
a/d degree who do you think you are get
back to where you were and suddenly you
realize you're outside of your comfort
zone and then the heater stopped and you
lose your drive and you begin to
self-sabotage yourself and you stop
doing what got you there in the first
place and you start doing some dumb
things making some dumb decisions until
you get back to exactly where you think
you deserve to be now how many of you
all know I'm sure none of you have done
this but how many of you have seen other
people sabotage themselves
yeah I thought so I thought so you see
the strongest force in human personality
is the need to remain consistent with
how we see ourselves the strongest force
in human personality is the need to
remain consistent with how we see
ourselves so the image that we hold of
ourselves controls our successes and our
failures and also impacts every single
area of our life and rule number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is have a sense of urgency the
average human lifespan is 75 years
one-third of your life is spent sleeping
and outer third of your life is spent on
watching TV movies drinking and partying
traveling spending time with family and
friends playing video games commuting to
work buying groceries paying the bills
being stuck in traffic waiting in line
mowing the lawn cleaning up the house
and doing laundry 25 years left in the
first 18 years of your life you are
growing up you are learning to walk eat
run and talk you are totally dependent
parents and going to school because he
can't really think for yourself call
your own shots or know how to be your
own person that means you have
approximately seven years to make your
dreams come true and if you have a job
you probably spend most of that time
working for someone else instead of
building your own dream life is too
short to waste time on people who don't
lift you up or inspired you life is too
short to be living somebody else's dream
life is too short to wait life is too
short not to take chances life is too
short to wake up with
developed a sense of urgency into
pursuit of success and freedom you must
step up to live life on your own terms
you
[Music]
now I've got two very special deadlock
bonus clips on how to decide to be
successful and just keep trying that I
think you're really gonna enjoy but
before that I want to make sure we're
moving from consuming a video to now
actually taking action in your life for
your business so I've got three
questions for you to ask yourself and in
the answers write them in your journal
to yourself discuss them with a friend
or leave them down in the comments below
ready here we go question number one
what triggers can you put in your
environment to steer you towards success
question number two what will you do to
up your thermostat and raise your
standards and question number three what
is the most important habit that you
need to improve right now thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clips
while was born in Hong Kong right so I
emigrated to Canada when I was 14 years
old with no money no connections and
couldn't speak a word of English so you
can see when even when I still today I
speak with an accent I'll leave you an
accent so my mom and dad because they
were having some some issues and so my
mom decided that she didn't want to stay
in the relationship that's why we
emigrated to Canada and the time was so
young I was kind of like a punk kid yeah
I had no direction yeah I was getting
your fights and hanging around with the
wrong gang of people and it's just
always getting into trouble right and so
my mom my mom and dad got divorced when
I was 16 years old and and surely after
that my dear went bankrupt in Hong Kong
and the time my mom and I we were living
in a one-bedroom apartment okay in one
of the worst neighborhoods in Vancouver
Wow so I remember I was my mom would
stay in the in the bedroom I would sleep
in the living room fight with sew on the
floor basically I remember one day after
Scott went home door was locked and I
knocked on my mom's door she was on the
phone with somebody I didn't know who
but I heard that she was crying on the
phone and it's like hey mom mom is
everything okay I was like oh I know
everything so don't worry about it and
afterwards basically I found that she
was on the phone with my dad and my dad
basically my mom he went bankrupt
he couldn't send us money anymore it's
at first he was sending us some
allowance right and I my mom is a very
very positive happy person like she's
like one of those people that she's
friends with everybody
like I said no enemies right just a
sweet sweet sweet person so and I'll
never forget the face on my mom like
that face that facial expression just so
hopeless and she was like now I'm gonna
do
I've been housewife all my life how am I
gonna raise this kid with with no money
with little savings and shoots she
wasn't working at that time you know
then you're 16 at this time as well 16
17 about 17
and from then on I said to myself I
don't care what I have to do I don't
want to see that face on my mum anymore
yeah yeah I don't care what it takes
I don't care what how hard after work
that's I think the turning point the
planet a seat right where I know that as
a man we want to provide for the family
of course and we want to but I think as
a man we cannot protect the people that
we love if we don't have the resources
right it could be financial but if we
don't have the resources and that's when
I made a decision I'm going to be
successful because unless I'm successful
I cannot provide for the people that I
love I cannot protect the people I love
and that was it from then on that's the
only child and that's when I started my
first business if you ask me the
question right Oh Dan what why what kept
me going was the motivation there's no
motivation every time I fail in a
business venture I was further and
further in debt so by the time I feel I
feel 13 businesses before having my
first success after you fail so many
businesses I was so I was in so much
debt if I was just to get a job I would
never pay that off it would take me 20
years to pay that off so it's more like
I'm back to the corner I have no way out
I gotta make it work so now I thought to
myself I just gotta keep trying and if I
can just make it and then it'll be fine
and that's exactly what it is so I mean
if you're in debt that don't think about
if you are I want to save a few pennies
let's not join the Starbucks coffee in
the morning if there makes a difference
it's not gonna make a difference
you need to focus on wealth creation so
you make more money then you can wipe
out the debt in a short period of time
right now turistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful and
why I'm here I think because I am so
open I wanted to think and see it's a
bloody brief life all of you have the
potential for enormous success if you
want to know what garyvee DJ khalid
oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video